[Music]
next the relationship between mind body
and emotion with antonio demacio author
of looking for spinoza and martha
nussbaum author of upheavals of thought
it's one hour
good afternoon my name is ron grossman
and behalf on behalf of the chicago
tribune for whom i work
welcome to the book fair and to this
afternoon's discussion
i think that the one line
that most people remember from
philosophy 101 is kogito
descartes famous discovery of himself as
a thinking being
you remember he was glitching about he
couldn't notice he couldn't know that
finally decided the one thing he did
know was that he was glitching about
wanting to know
that solved his problem
but it created one in the history of
thought that
is called the mind-body problem
it happens that in february of this year
the newspaper sent me
well that's not quite correct i kept
twitching about wanting to go until they
finally said well just send him to the
annual meeting of the metaphysical
society of america
and the keynote spoke speaker spoke very
eloquently about how descartes and his
influence had created a split between
our sense of self as mind and our sense
of self as body between the part of
ourselves that science seems to study
the part of ourselves that philosophers
seem to write about that was most
unfortunate
and all 17 of us in attendance at the
metaphysical society of america's
meetings we ducked our chins up and down
like that
we are very fortunate this afternoon to
have with us in conversation
uh two eminent scholars who represent
both sides of that historic
dilemma
in the first instance coming from the
side of the body
no that's too easy coming from the side
of the body is professor antonio damasio
who is professor of neurology in fact
van allen distinguished service
professor of neurology at the university
of iowa and author of the recently
published looking for for spinoza
also with us is uh professor martha c
nussbaum
author of upheavals of thought the
intelligence of the emotions
and uh the paul fryen distinguished
service professor of philosophy at the
university of chicago in the department
of philosophy the law school the school
of religion et cetera et cetera right on
down the line
i i was reading each of their books the
other night and i was struck by a
similarity of approach
both in terms of their unwillingness to
be bound by those the economies of
science versus philosophy and also of
tackling a problem the human emotions
that both the scientists and the
philosophers have until recently just
stood aside from i thought to start it
off i'd read you a brief passage from
each of their books and then you can see
i hope what what i'm talking about
professor demacio writes when i started
musing about how the brain managed to
create the mind i accepted a literal
translation he must have been a graduate
student at the time and knew better to
challenge the accepted wisdom of his
elders
i accepted
that
one could study sensory processes
visually and otherwise and understand
how things are put together one could
study how the brain learns and memorizes
thoughts one could even study the
emotional reactions with which we
respond to varied objects and events but
feelings which can be distinguished from
emotions remain elusive feelings were
forever to stay mysterious they were
private and inaccessible it was not
possible to explain how feedings
happened or where they happened one
simply got
beyond feelings
professor nussbaum writes
if emotions are suffused with
intelligence and discernment
and if they contain in themselves an
awareness of value or importance they
cannot for example easily sideline in
accounts of ethical judgment as so often
they have been in the history of
philosophy
instead of viewing morality as a system
of principles to be grasped by the
detached intellect and emotions as
motivations that either support or
subvert our choice to act according to
principle we will have to consider
emotions as part and parcel of the
system of ethical reasoning we cannot
plausibly admit them once we acknowledge
that emotions include in their content
judgments that can be true or false or
good or bad guides to ethical thought
i hope you could hear in those two
passages
the fact the very interesting fact that
not only do our two panelists today
consider the same problem but they are
the rarest of all inhabitants of the
ivory tower professors who can write not
only for themselves and other academics
but in a clear
and concise manner that the rest of us
can understand it is my pleasure then to
present to you martha nussbaum and
antonio dimacio in conversation
[Music]
[Applause]
we set the following ground rules at
least for us i hope you will
accept them that each of the professors
would speak briefly then they'll speak
among themselves and then hopefully not
too late in the proceedings we'll get
folks in the audience into the
conversation too the tv folks ask that
if you want to ask a question please get
yourself close to that microphone up on
my right hand side back there
we flipped a coin and our visitor from
iowa is the first speaker
thank you very much
can you hear me at the back
microphone is not on
can you hear me now
good now we have a non-microphone
well um
let me start by making a reference to
the new book since that was just
mentioned
the title of the book is looking for
spinoza
and there is a title that may appear
quite enigmatic to many of you but the
book does have a subtitle and the
subtitle is joy sorrow in the in the
feeling brain
and then it's quite transparent because
it reflects the focus of the book
uh first the fact that i'm interested in
elucidating how a living organism and in
particular the brain of a living
organism manages to process emotions
and that specifically i wish to
understand how we experience emotions
that is how we feel emotions
and as our kind moderator just mentioned
the idea that we can't understand
the neurobiology behind feelings
is an idea that has been late to come to
science in fact for a very long time not
only were emotions given the cold
shoulder of neuroscience but feelings
even more so
now the perspective that i have in this
this work is obviously my perspective as
a neurologist and neurobiologist
[Music]
but i want to make clear that
the neuroscience of mind and behavior
does not exist in a vacuum
for example i attempt in our work to
connect with psychology in the
traditional sense and psychoanalysis
with anthropology and with philosophy
among many other fields and i also want
to make clear that although my main goal
in my work in general and in this book
in particular is to understand
neurobiological mechanisms
but what i want to understand is really
the brain machinery as it were
i'm not really interested in the kind of
reductive approaches that
take biological phenomena out of their
usual context and especially take
biological phenomena out of the human
context which is the one that i'm most
interested in
so
in trying to be brief i made a little
list of what i think is key in a
discussion of this sort and which in a
way summarizes
the main points of the book the center
part of the book and that is that there
is quite a lot that is new to report on
the neurobiology of emotion and feelings
in fact there has been a spectacular
development in this area and a very
rapid one because if we go back even 10
years we find that
neuroscience
and its connected fields were not
terribly interested in approaching this
problem or the problem of consciousness
for that matter the two being sort of
the last
holdouts for neuroscience
but this has changed very dramatically
so that in fact right now
every year there is quite a lot that is
new and interesting to report if i would
make a very brief summary i would say
the following
point number one
that emotions have an evolutionary past
and have been part of the behavior of
many other species for quite a long time
in other words
emotions are not
an aspect of our mind and behavior that
is specific to humans on the contrary
they have been available in many other
species which is very interesting for a
variety of reasons
second that emotions are at their core
and i'm here doing a very narrow
definition
unlearned but very intelligent reactions
to certain objects and situations some
which can be out in the world others
that are in fact inside ourselves
and that those intelligent but unlearned
reactions contribute directly or
indirectly to survival and to well-being
and i think the idea that they
contribute to survival directly or
indirectly has been for a very long time
part of our understanding but the idea
that
directly or indirectly they contribute
to well-being is something that i want
to emphasize and that deserves
uh
discussion because i think that at their
best
if we cultivate them right emotions are
key to the flourishing of human beings
to the flourishing of our minds
now
this contribution to survival and
well-being is
something that is
naturally occurring for the benefit of
the organism that emotes
but also for other organisms that are
related to it sometimes for the group of
organisms that is having that particular
emotion to give you a contrasting
example when we have fear
we have an emotion and we can have the
experience the feeling of fear and that
tends to be extremely valuable to the
organism that has the fear it is
probably fear is probably one of the
main reasons why so many individual
organisms have been saved in the history
of biology
but the the effect the result of having
fear has that consequence that benefit
largely for the individual however when
you take another
example of emotion the emotion of
compassion or sympathy
the one that
undergirds the feeling of empathy as it
turns out the benefit is not only for
the self not only for the individual
having the emotion of compassion but
actually primarily for the individual
that receives the compassion the
sympathy
and so this is very interesting because
here we project through some of these
natural intelligent
automated reactions we project from the
individual into others which is
something that may lead us to an
interesting discussion on why emotions
are so important not just to regulate
our life but also to regulate regulate
the life of a society of a group of
individuals and that is something that i
know martin luther
is also very interested in
now emotions next point involve of
necessity certain classes of behavior
that produce reward or punishment which
are ultimately perceived by
humans as pain or pleasure or some
gradation in between
and now comes a point that is very
important and probably is the critical
one in terms of our research and that is
that emotions involve of necessity the
body
the body of
the person that has the emotion either
actually
by
changing the state of the body by
creating in the theater of the body an
upheaval which is a word that martin
luther also uses in our title
or by
making that change in a simulation
that we make of our own body inside our
brains and this is the very key aspect
and is different from the traditional
view because as many of you know there
is a classical view of the phenomenon of
emotion that came to us via william
james in which the body was actually the
body all the time
and
the view that we are defending is one in
which the body can be involved and is
absolutely critical but does not need to
be necessarily involved all the time
because as
it happens we possess
a dynamically constructed
continuously constructed model of our
own body inside our brains in regions of
the brain that literally look and
monitor the body and because of that we
have the power not only to act out our
emotions in the body itself but we have
the power also of simulating the
emotions within this very dynamic model
inside our brains which by the way does
not resemble at all a classical
homunculus it's actually made up of
multiple neural maps in different
regions of the brain interconnected in
very curious ways
final two points feelings
of emotion are in fact perceptions of
the emotive state once that emotive
state is generated but perceptions that
are in close connection to the object
that caused those emotions in the first
place and to the thoughts that ensue
from the entire process of emoting and
perceiving the changes that
are part of emotion
and the final
point about
modern research is that we can now
detail
many of the brain systems that are
involved in emotion and feeling for
example
we have a sense now of the regions of
the brain that operate to create the
process of appraisal or evaluation that
leads to an emotion because
emotions require that process which by
the way can be non-conscious and
emotions in a certain way can be seen as
evaluations themselves as judgments on
the state in which an organism is at a
given moment in the world
but we know now many of the regions that
process this appraisal or evaluation we
also know the regions that cause
the triggering the
the induction of the emotion and for
example i mentioned fear
and we know that one of the key parts of
the system that leads to fear is a
structure known as the amygdala which
sits in the anterior part of our
temporal lobe
and
that triggering that the amygdala
participates in is then going to
lead to the next process which is that
of the execution of the emotion itself
which occurs in the body itself or in
the simulation that i mentioned before
in those regions of the brain
that map out the body continuously
but for example for the emotion that i
also referred earlier the emotion of
compassion it turns out that the
amygdala is not a key but another
triggering region a region of the
ventromedial frontal lobe is in fact
quite important so this gives you an
idea that in the way the brain operates
to generate these emotions you have
different components that are
articulated with each other to create a
system
and
those components
vary according to the emotions some are
shared but some are very distinct with
the amygdala for example being important
for fear but not for compassion and the
ventromedial frontal lobe being more
important for compassion than for fear
finally we have a very good sense now of
the structures that allow you to get
a mental take
a mental
appreciation of what is going on in a
variety of these processes that can
occur either in the body itself or in
the as if body that we possess in our
brains
i would like to close by saying that
there is of course a historical context
to all of the work that is being done
now and a historical context that goes
to the very beginning of philosophy we
could talk for example and that's
something that martha nussbaum no doubt
will do about
the link between understanding emotion
and the work of aristotle or the work of
the historic philosophers but there are
two philosophers that i think are very
key
more close to us to the the modern
understanding of emotion and feeling and
they are william james whom i mentioned
and i think it's important to mention
william james who happens to be one of
my intellectual heroes because
although he's in insight in what into
what emotions and feelings are i think
is absolutely brilliant it turns out to
be rather narrow for my own taste
and definitely incomplete
it also happens that
william james was very criticized for
his approach to the emotions and in my
view quite unfairly leaving aside the
incompleteness and the narrowness of his
account there is no doubt that many of
the attacks especially the ones that
came from the site of neuroscience were
very ill founded in fact they come from
experiments that were grossly
misinterpreted so this is something
interesting to discuss
the other is that in a way spinoza who
gives the main title to this book
is someone who preceded
much of the thinking of william james in
a variety of ways which i'm not going to
discuss right now but which are quite
curious he had although he was not a
biologist and he had no access to
studies of the brain itself
he had in a way a protobiological mind
and he anticipated
to my way of seeing not only many of the
things that william james said about
emotion but also what claude bernard a
famous french physiologist said late in
the 19th century and even what darwin
said about many aspects that have to do
with the
sources of the processes that we have in
our minds and in our behavior
the reason however why spinoza is in the
title is that in addition to
his his role in emotion which until a
few years ago i was not uh
fully aware of i was aware that he had
studied it i was not aware
of the degree to which
he was modern in the sense that he can
be seen as a precursor to current ideas
but the reason why i was really
fascinated by spinoza is that spinoza
sees a connection that is very powerful
and direct between emotions and
ethical behavior
and this is one aspect of the study of
emotions that i regard is very important
and one in which our laboratory
is doing quite a lot of work
so i thought it was important for
people who think about neuroscience to
know about spinoza and about these
contributions and to also know about how
spinoza wanted to project
his work into
the future of our understanding of
ethics and to close i would just say
that when we look at emotions
it's quite clear that emotions are
involved in the maintenance
of
the equilibrium that is necessary for
life that is necessary for the survival
of our bodies there is a term to
describe that equilibrium which is the
word homeostasis
and when we look at this
with a very long perspective
we
become aware of the fact that there is a
system of automated homeostasis which
involves our metabolic regulation our
immune system
drives and motivations
rewarding punishment mechanisms and
emotions
but then there's something else that has
to do also with homeostasis but in the
very broad context
uh in which we live currently in a
complex
society in a complex not only physical
but social environment and that is an
homeostasis that requires the regulation
of social behavior as well
and
i think the intriguing thing is to
realize that that homeostatic process
which is not automated and which is
achieved by social conventions and
ethical rules and laws
and
social and political organization is in
fact connected by a sort of umbilical
cord to the very process of emotions it
is something that does not have millions
of years of
history it is something that has in fact
been evolving for just a few thousand
years and probably for that reason is
quite quite imperfect
but nonetheless it is there and i think
the reason for optimism is that
we can see how those mechanisms can
evolve into the fu in the future when
you have human beings that are aware of
their own minds that are aware of their
um
knowledge and that can reason
intelligently
over what is in fact available in the
situations that
they are
inserted
especially they can reason over whether
or not emotions are or certain emotions
are positive or negative in order to
maintain that social regulation that i'm
talking about and i will stop right here
thank you antonio
martin okay uh can you hear me
okay i want to start with the passage
from which my title upheavals of thought
is taken because i think this will give
you a sense of where i'm
beginning in this book it's a passage
from proust in which the narrator marcel
is describing the baron de charlus who
has just fallen in love and he's talking
about what falling in love did to this
baron's mind
and he says it's almost impossible to
understand the extent to which this
upheaval agitated and by that very fact
had temporarily enriched the mind of
monsieur de charles
love in this way produces real
geological upheavals of thought
in the mind of monsieur de charles which
only several days before resembled a
plane so flat that even from a good
vantage point one could not have seen an
idea sticking up above the ground a
mountain range should suddenly thrust
itself into view hard as rock but
mountains sculptured as if an artist
instead of taking the marble away had
worked it there on the spot and where
they're twisted around one another in
giant and swollen groupings rage
jealousy curiosity envy hate
suffering pride astonishment
and love
so emotions proust is saying shape the
landscape of our mental and social lives
like these geological upheavals
that a traveler might discover in a
landscape where only a flat plain could
be seen only a day before
they mark our lives as uneven precarious
and prone to reversal
why and how
is it because emotions are animal
energies or impulses that have no
connection with our thoughts imaginings
and appraisals
proust denies this calling emotions
geological upheavals of thought
in other words what changes the baron's
mind from a flat plane into a mountain
range is not some subterranean jolt of
energy but rather the thoughts he has
about charlie morrell a person who has
suddenly become absolutely central to
his well-being and whom he sees as
inscrutable undependable and utterly
beyond his control it's these thoughts
about
significance and importance that make
his mind project outward like a mountain
range rather than sitting in inert and
self-satisfied ease
so in the first part of the book i i
don't turn to love yet because i think
that's actually one of the most complex
emotions so it forms part three of the
book but i ask the reader to consider
grief so i'd like to ask you now to just
focus on some example in your own past
of grief for the death of someone you
love
i talk in the book about my own grief at
the death of my mother
if you think about the grief
and you think about the idea that
emotions might be just
jolts of energy that have no connection
with thoughts imaginings and plans i
want to say that i think you see five
reasons why that view is totally
inadequate first of all if you think
about grieving for someone you love you
see that the emotion
has an object it's directed toward
that person who's lost
and second the object is what
philosophers call
an intentional object that is to say
your mind is not just directed toward
that person in the way that an arrow is
directed towards its target but the
directedness is internal it involves a
way of seeing your grieving contains an
image of the person who has died
third point the emotion also
involves beliefs about what has happened
and about that person in grief involves
very centrally the thought that the
person is gone and will never come again
and then
fourth
the beliefs are not just beliefs about
matters of fact but they also include
evaluations
because in your grief you're ascribing
significance to that person we grieve
for the people we view as central in our
lives and not for people we don't know
we in in the grief itself the idea of
the person's tremendous importance
is involved in the very way you
experience that emotion
and then finally
fifth the emotions see that importance
not just from some impersonal point of
view on the world but rather from the
point of view of your own life from your
own goals and projects that is what what
you think when you're grieving and
what's internal to that grief is the
idea of the person's tremendous
significance in your view on the world
so that's i think part of why we do
agree for the people we we know with
whom our lives have been intertwined and
we don't grieve for people we don't know
so those are the
five reasons why i want to say the
jolt of energy view of emotions is
totally inadequate and i go on to
develop that in much more detail in the
first part of the group the book
and this
has a historical side like antonio i'm
very interested in the history in
philosophy of these
more
complicated and interesting views of
emotion and i trace my own partly to
aristotle and partly to the greek and
roman stoics who really did think that
emotions were mental and they actually
had a great influence on spinoza later
on
and so spinoza is also very close to
this view that i'm developing
but then
i want to say that that view of emotions
as involving thoughts about value and
importance is still
too simple it's too simple in the way
that the stoics develop it and in the
rest of the first part of the book i try
to make it more complicated in three
ways first of all we have to
talk about how we understand this idea
of thought because the stoics
understood thought in a very
verbal way they thought what emotions
involved was accepting something like a
linguistically formulated proposition
and so for that reason they thought that
animals just didn't have emotions and
young children didn't have them either
and that aspect of the view is i think
quite implausible there's lots of reason
to think that most animals really do
have many emotions anyway certainly fear
is very widely distributed
and even compassion i think quite a few
animals do have
so
then we have to talk about what we mean
by emotions contain thoughts and i then
broaden the notion of thought to include
ways of seeing an object as significant
that needn't involve the possession of
language or the ability to put that into
language so that's the first
modification so it's kind of seeing
something as very significant that
doesn't necessarily involve language the
second modification is we have to i
think get clear about the tremendous
importance of society in shaping
people's emotions i think antonio is
right that some emotions are don't
involve much learning but a lot of the
emotions that we carry around in our
daily lives involve quite a lot of
learning and that learning is social if
you think about your experience of grief
again
how you grieve depends on what you think
death is and that's something that
you've been taught if you've been taught
that it means the person goes away and
never comes back again
uh well that gives your grief a certain
texture if you think the person is
happily existing somewhere else and you
will join that person that gives your
grief a slightly different texture so
all these beliefs that we learn in
society
inhabit the internal life of our
emotions they're not just external to
them but i want to say they color them
they make them up for example again if
you think if you've been brought up to
think that
erotic attraction is something
disgusting and not very good for human
beings to have that will color the
texture of the erotic love that you will
experience it's not just external to it
but it enters into it so that's the
second modification
the third modification is we need to do
what proofs does throughout his
wonderful novel and that is provide the
emotions with a history
we start having emotions very very early
in life
and the early emotions that we have
in a way
get
transcended and changed but in a way
they don't in a way our primitive
longing for sources of comfort and
nourishment
sticks around in human life and it may
inhabit in ways that we aren't aware of
our later loves bruce narrator becomes
aware gradually that his own
strangely possessive and destructive
love of women
is the result of a kind of primitive
longing for his mother's embrace
that has never gone away and he's never
been able to transcend it now he he's
got a pretty um
sort of determined fatalistic view about
that he thinks one never can in any way
transcend any aspect of one's childhood
and one might not agree with that but i
think one does want to say that
childhood the childhood one has had
sticks around and often inhabits one's
adult emotions in ways that are very
complicated and that we're not entirely
aware of
so having made all these modifications i
then turn to two emotions that are of
particular interest to me
one is indeed love and that forms the
whole third part of the book but since
that's so complex and i look at literary
texts of many different kinds as well as
philosophical texts i want to just
conclude here by saying a few words
about compassion which i think is
a very very important emotion as antonio
has also said for thinking about society
and how we relate to other people
now there is in the history of
philosophy and debate about compassion
there are a group of philosophers who
think that compassion is
is a mess that it's a bad guide to
social life that it just
skews our public debate in ways that
make us undependable
irrational uneven so therefore we should
just cast it aside and rely on motives
based on
moral principle alone
then there's another group
we could mention
aristotle schopenhauer
john dewey they're very different kinds
of philosophers who think that
compassion is
essential and illuminable if we want to
drag ourselves out of our rootedness in
our own ideas and projects it's an
essential bridge to the reality of
another person's good and ill and so if
we try to do without it then we're
likely to lapse back into some something
like uh egoism and some something much
worse than
an uneven compassion would be
but uh so what i do is i go through the
thoughts involved in compassion and say
that if we
understand these thoughts then we can
see
where and how compassion is likely to go
wrong
compassion involves the thought that
someone else is
suffering in some significant way that
the suffering is not entirely that
person's own fault that we ourselves are
vulnerable in certain similar ways and
then finally i want to add uh that it it
involves this
idea about our own goals and projects
that i've mentioned before compassion we
will only have compassion for the
suffering of somebody that we've always
already managed to make central to our
own idea of our goals and projects in
life
so what this means is that compassion is
indeed uneven we have compassion for
people we can relate to ourselves not
for people who are total strangers to us
and so that does give one point to the
enemies of compassion on the other hand
it is a very powerful motive to care and
act on behalf of the good of other
people and
i turn here to some psychological
evidence that shows that that compassion
is closely linked to helping behavior so
i conclude that we really need to keep
compassion around motives based on
impartial principle may not be powerful
enough to really jolt us out of our
egoism to get us to care about other
people but on the other hand it is
defective as we mostly live it and know
it and so education will have to try to
extend compassion by making the good of
others who are distant from ourselves
real significant and important to us so
i'll just close there
did you want to say something about it
do you understand or i could what do you
replace
let me interject something that i heard
in your two presentations that i found
very interesting
each of you
took your inspiration from your remarks
for your remarks today from
somebody external to your own fields
martha read from the works of a french
novelist
and
antonio uh spoke of a
jewish philosopher and
an american philosopher i i wonder if
that touches on the issue of how central
the emotions are to us
that until recently until almost just
before these two books scholars didn't
want to face up to the nature of the
problem of the human emotions
i i would say so i i think it goes to
that issue it also goes to something
quite interesting is that
there are many ways of knowing
and
i think that very often in a society
that has been in a culture that has been
so touched by spectacular scientific
discoveries
one has the idea that science is going
to do it
for all aspects of knowledge for all as
for all questions and this is quite
false i think and i think that
first of all we have an obligation
whether we are biologists or or
working on some other aspect of science
of connecting with the science of the
past with the thinking of the past
because there are very few questions and
certainly not emotion and feeling
that have been treated by thinkers for
millennia and i think we have an
obligation to connect with
the approach that others had before us
but the other is that there is actually
a practical advantage it's not just a
question of paying our dues to those
that came before us and thought about
the same problems is that there's much
to be gained
in many of those approaches and this
also extends not just philosophers
because philosophers were doing science
before science was science but also to
many fields of the humanities and
certainly to literature
where you have i i love the way martha
has used
writers and music to make her points and
our investigations have used not only
inspiration but actual facts from those
accounts literary accounts and how they
can be meshed into
what we call modern thinking scientific
or otherwise so i think it it's part of
an approach that
goes away from the
self-containment and sometimes arrogance
of a single discipline to open into
other disciplines and i think we have
everything to gain and nothing much to
lose by doing so
yeah i think
the study of the emotions has gotten
exciting and good precisely because of
interdisciplinarity
for a long time philosophers only talked
about other philosophical views once in
a while they did talk about a novel or a
poem because they could hardly get
get their own examples to be as
interesting as the literary examples but
more recently
and this is what i try to do in my book
they've gotten much more in touch with
science
with cognitive psychology
also with anthropology i do think that's
very important because there are
excellent studies by anthropologists of
the emotion
vocabulary and the emotional taxonomy of
particular societies and i use those
quite a lot in shaping my view of the
social aspect of emotions i'm also very
interested in psychoanalysis not
everyone who reads the book will agree
but i actually try to bring proust in at
the same time because i think actually
what some of the greatest psychoanalysts
tell us about emotional development is
also
very close to what proust is doing so if
one doesn't like
freud and winnicott one might well like
the part on proofs um
but
i i do feel that right now it would be
very foolhardy for anyone in philosophy
to ignore these other disciplines which
have shown us such a great deal
one other thing that i wanted to say is
that of course there's one aspect to the
work in neurobiology on neuroscience in
general that is quite critical we did
not discuss it and it has to do
with one very practical payoff i think
that you're all aware that there are all
sorts of conditions having to do with
the emotions for example
pain
physical pain or depression
that can only be
correctly treated or managed in a broad
sense once we have some kind of detailed
view of how emotions to begin with
operate in a human brain
and i think that we're we're of course
we've made progress and it's obvious
that there are available today forms of
treatment
typically biomedical or therapeutic in
the sense of psychoanalysis and other
therapies that are of course much better
than they were
a while ago but they're very far from
delivering the goods in terms of
alleviating human suffering and i think
that a lot of the work that is being
done in neurobiology
is not just aimed at answering our
curiosity which i would consider
would be a wonderful goal but also at
trying to establish the grounds for
developments in future treatments and
that's something that is important
uh at this point i'd like to invite the
audience to share their emotional life
with our uh panelists does anybody have
a brief question because we are running
a little short on time
yes closest to the microphone back there
well first of all let me say that
in more than
just today the two of you have helped
open
i think an enormously productive future
inquiry into
mankind and it's multi-disciplinary
aspects
i've read one of the books
professor news bombs i have not not seen
the other one yet except
to get a nan
but uh the one thing i was interested in
was
i imagine that one or both of you has
probably seen stephen winter's book
on uh
the
the forest in the valley
well it was recently published by the
university of chicago press
uh it has a marvelous reference and by
the way professor newspaper
he frequently uh talks about how
impressed he is by your work
um
but
he's a he brings into this area the
the fundamental problem of justice and
justice being an essence
of thought
that varies not only by culture but by
individual experiences
and i was going to ask you
if you had any thought
about the development
into other into interdisciplinary things
the utilization in the future for
example in the area of judging or of law
or of nurturing now it seems to me that
nurturing is the essence of justice
and miss professor newspam you came very
very very close to that as a as a
fundamental
if you want to make it as the first step
towards love
okay let me try i i do uh like steve
winter's articles but i haven't seen the
book so i i won't try to comment on on
the book um
what i am doing right now as it just
happens is writing a book about two
particular emotions shame and disgust
that have played a very big role in the
law and i think a very problematic role
and i think the kind of
complicated account that i try to offer
of emotions and upheavals of thought
may puts us in a position where we can
then give a more nuanced analysis of
these two particular emotions and say
some things to adjudicate the debate
between people for example who want to
bring back punishments based on shaming
and people who oppose that and comment
on the issues of justice involved again
the debate between people like lord
devlin but also like more recently leon
cass who think that the emotion of
disgust is a very good guide to law and
public policy and then others myself
included who think it's actually a very
bad god to law and public policy so i
think we can't sort through those
debates without having a nuanced
understanding of the particular emotions
and so that's what i'm
working on now and now that's one way
the emotions connect with justice anyway
yes please
well i can't help but commenting that
this
tent is called the heartland tent as you
talk about your run the geography of the
uh of the emotions
but the question is this uh there's been
a great deal of research
in terms of emotions as they're
integrated into experience
in sleep
and in dreaming and i wonder if each of
the
speakers could comment on the role of of
sleep in the integration and the
refinement
of emotions uh through
uh emotional uh integration as well as
through dreaming
uh well there's
there's an obvious connection between
emotions and sleep but i must start by
saying that
there is not much known in fact about
the interrelation and as there is not
much known or not as much known as there
should be about sleep itself
one thing that is for certain is that
one of the prominent aspects of our
dream sleep
has to do with emotions emotions figure
very prominently they can be positive
they can be negative
uh
fear
anxieties play quite often but
fortunately so do the flourishing
positive emotions uh you can wake up
after a very happy dream
um
it is
quite likely and this is strictly my
view
it does
i don't think the science to back it is
there it is quite likely that
during periods of
dream sleep
uh in which we are
aware
because we have a paradoxical
consciousness we are aware of the fact
that we have emotions we are working
through
some
of the problems of the day or some of
the problems that preoccupy us uh over a
certain epoch or season of course
against that view there will be the view
of those that would say that the
appearance of certain topics in the
dream and of certain emotions connected
to those topics is actually random
nonetheless i think we all have
some
personal sense that this is not random
at least all the time and that there is
a connection and that that connection
can probably have some solitary effects
in our in our lives
but almost anything that we do in
relation to sleep and dreams and of
course their connection to emotion needs
to recognize that we still do not know
why we dream for example we still do not
know
why we sleep even there are all sorts of
very nice reasons that suggest
that we do it for restoration of
the processes of our brain
but in fact we cannot we do not have the
evidence to respond definitively to
those to those
in fact questions about dreams i i guess
because there that's one place where i'd
have to spend a lot of time either
defending or or or refuting the
psychoanalytic accounts of dreaming and
i think although i myself find
the ford's account very attractive i i
you know i'm aware that there are these
alternative accounts and i didn't feel
that i was in a position to uh sort all
that out i mean i think it just did
strike me that the evidence is very
murky and unclear at that point
we have time for just one more brief
question hopefully of the true false
variety
i'm writing my second book about
concentration camps
could you stand closer to the microphone
we can't hear you up here
i'm writing now my second book about
concentration camps where i was
and i wonder
why so many scholars
don't mention or push aside
the strong emotion which did
appear in concentration camp
they just make cool logic
and don't want to speak about emotions
i couldn't i mean i i heard that you
wanted to know why scholars didn't talk
about the strong emotions that are
experienced in concentration camps is
that that the question
um
i i find this a very interesting topic
and i actually think i mean todderoff
has written about this and others have
uh kristen monroe has written about
kristin monroe has written a very good
book about the emotions of the rescuers
and i think that's actually quite
interesting uh as a study in what brings
about the extraordinary kind of
compassion that people had to have in
order to be rescuers of the jews but
todderoff has written i think quite well
about the emotions in the camps and
about instances of where
you know the breakdown of morality
wasn't total where the everyday kindness
and compassion survived the deliberate
dehumanization of others and and so on
so um i think there is some good writing
about that of course primo levy is is
most important
my own um work intersects with that in
this book on shame and disgust because i
do feel that both of those emotions are
emotions that are standardly used to
dehumanize and brutalize other people
they did play a prominent role in the
attempt to dehumanize the jews in the
camps and so um so then the question is
how could one prevent that from
succeeding in a given instance
i see by the clock that we have time to
introduce only one more emotion and
that's uh far blungeon
as i noticed one or two non yiddish
speakers in the audience let me define
that as it was in the golden age of
catskill comedy when the baggy pants
comedian would come up to the microphone
and said that that's the feeling you
have
when you hear that your mother-in-law
went over a cliff but in your catalog
catalog cadillac i'm sorry
i'm feeling a bit far-blunded myself
very pleased and happy at the course of
our discussion today and just a little
bit sad that it's got to come to close
now so why don't we thank not available
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
harcourtbooks.com
and learn more about martha nussbaum's
upheavals of thought at the cambridge
university press website cup.org
it's book tv's fifth anniversary this
fall on c-span